أول شيء أريد أن أطرحه عليك هو أننا
غالبًا لا نفكر كثيرًا في
الخطوة المضادة للطرف الآخر ،
لذلك كنا نخوض هذه
الحرب غير المسبوقة ضد فلاديمير بوتين ،
كيف تعتقد أن بوتين يفكر
فيها و  ما هو رده الأكثر ترجيحًا
هو أننا نرى بالفعل
بعضًا منهم
جيدًا. فريد أه رد بوتين المحتمل
الذي رأيناه بالفعل وهو
أه أعتقد تفجير خط الأنابيب هذا خارج
روسيا الذي كان يوفر الغاز الطبيعي
لأوروبا
أم  أه بالاقتران مع بلدنا كما
لاحظت حظر الواردات من النفط الروسي أه
سنخلق وضعًا هنا
حيث أه الكثير من الدول الأوروبية
سيكون بها شتاء شديد البرودة وغير
مريح وأسعار الغاز والنفط
حول العالم  سيكون
مرتفعًا للغاية وأعتقد أن هذا هو
أساسًا هيل ماري من بوتين لريد
حيث سيرمي أكبر عدد من
القوات إلى أوكرانيا للحفاظ على الأرض على
أمل أن ترتفع أسعار النفط إلى أعلى مستوى
ممكن في فصل الشتاء.
ليختار بين
التسخين والأكل وأم
والضغط عليه ويأمل أه على الأوكرانيين
أن يبرموا معه صفقة قذرة